some psychedelic drugs induce mystical
experiences which give people a sense of
a much wider and more intense and
encompassing form of love than any
they've known in the more limited human
Realm
[Music]
Love is All You Need says the song from
the Christian tenet God is love to the
plots of countless novels and films love
is seen as Central to our lives yet from
scientific studies along with anecdotal
accounts we know that psychoactive
substances and MDMA in particular can
enhance and even induce intense feelings
of love if love can be hacked by a
change in brain chemistry might our
romanticized idea of Love itself be the
distortion
should we use drugs to encourage
initiate and repair relationships as
some therapists Advocate or are such
experiences false damaging and
potentially socially dangerous Islam are
products of brain chemistry or is it
something deeper than a drug could ever
replicate so onto our speakers and as
Samberg is a philosopher and research
fellow at the future of humanity
Institute at Oxford he describes himself
as an academic jack of all trades Ella
Whelan is a political commentator and
freelance journalist and author of what
women want fun freedom and an end to
feminism Rupert sheldrake is a biologist
author and researcher Rupert is author
of books like the science delusion and
ways to go beyond and why they work
thank you so much to all of our
panelists for being here we're going to
kick off with a three minute pitch that
means you have three minutes to lay out
your position on the question of should
we use drugs to initiate encourage or
repair love Rupert
I didn't know I was going first I
thought I was going last
I'm just relaxing and waiting to hear
what you need a minute all right
um well first of all I don't think
Love's just romantic love it's obvious
there's many kinds I'm a biologist and
if you think about the way in which
mother animals will protect their young
most of us would think of that as a form
of love I certainly would and in the
human realm romantic love is obviously
one kind
but also parental love is another and
there are many other forms of love in
our society the love between friends and
so on
um so
love isn't just a feeling it's a kind of
bond or connection between people which
has effects if you love somebody or care
for them look after them when they're
sick care about them and it's what you
do is actually more important than what
you feel of course the feelings help the
action but we all know that a lot of
people can talk about love in a way that
sounds impressive but when it comes to
action there are other people who don't
talk about it who are actually much more
loving
um
so that's one point another point is
that the
um
the Christian view of of love and and
many other religious views of Love Is
that we live ultimately in a universe
where the ultimate Consciousness that on
which all our conscious Minds depend is
basically loving even though terrible
things happen in the world there's
something loving about Ultimate Reality
and this is something many people
experience through mystical experiences
many people have the experience of being
in the loving presence of a greater
consciousness
and that can indeed be enhanced by drugs
some psychedelic drugs induce mystical
experiences which give people a sense of
a much wider and more intense and
encompassing form of love than any
they've known in the more limited human
realm a kind of ultimate source of love
and that can lead to a sense of
connection with nature and with other
people that does lead to more loving
relationships
in relation to repairing relationships I
do think drugs can have a beneficial
effect
when I first took MDMA it was in the
early 1980s in California when it had
just been developed by Sasha Shogun and
was being tried out by small groups of
psychotherapists who were convinced it
would have this effect of enabling
people to respond to people they were in
tense relationships with without
lessening their fear enabling a greater
honesty in a way that could help repair
relationships it was utterly surprising
to me that this became a kind of dance
drug and part of Rave culture when it
was first
used it was not part of that simply
wasn't on the horizon it was it was seen
much more in a therapeutic setting and
interestingly we're now coming back to
the use of psychedelics and
mind-altering substances like MDMA
in the context of psychotherapy and
repairing damaged relationships within
families and between people
so I think drugs can enhance this by
reducing fear by opening us up to a
greater sense of conscious presence a
loving presence but I don't think Love's
all about altered brain chemistry I
think it's a much more fundamental
future of the universe and of animal
behavior thank you so much Anders over
to you should we use drugs to initiate
encourage or repair love
so I wrote an Ethics paper about this
one of the early ethics papers and then
you find out as an academic if you
struck gold because everybody wants to
debate it so it became a whole sequence
of papers and when I started thinking
about it I noticed that it seems that we
have three kinds of Love related systems
in the brain one is basically the sex
system mating with somebody that you can
mate with then you have a attraction
system finding somebody that you're
compatible with and then there is the
pair bonding system and they seem to
have slightly different neurochemical
substrates and you could imagine drugs
or other means that enhance different
them to different levels so I think the
sixth part we can leave aside for the
time being uh although that's kind of
the fun part but the nice thing about
the attraction system is of course okay
when you fall in love you feel something
extremely intense something extremely
pleasurable
but it's also problematic if you could
make people fall in love the Love Potion
we have in fairy tales and Other Stories
would be pretty horrifying if if it
actually existed in the real world if
I'm in love with somebody only because I
got the particular drug that seems to be
deeply inauthentic that seems to be from
a moral standpoint totally problematic
on the other hand once you have
established that your compatible with
somebody you start to grow together it's
a learning process that initial burst of
dopamine and other things is telling our
forebrains to learn everything we can
about each other we start developing
habits friendships and the things that
is actually sustainable not just through
a few months of a passion passionate
effort but instead over years staying
together and that pair bonding system
the interesting part is evolution has
obviously optimized us for staying
together long enough to rear our kids
but then we might want us humans to stay
together much longer than the kids are
around because we actually now
appreciate that Bond
unfortunately Evolution might not have
optimized that that one stays long
enough indeed in our evolution of
evolutionary adaptation we might
generally not have expected to survive
that long so this is where we might
validly say we might want to help that
system there might be a hint here that
the hormones excitus in a vasopressin
are used as neuromodulators in the brain
and there might be ways here of using
that to strengthen the pair of body this
is where we get links to MDMA which also
affects oxytocin system and this is
where I think we have a pretty clear
moral case that yeah if we have couples
that want to stay together obviously
couples therapy works but we might want
to enhance that as much as possible so I
do think that yes there are drugs that
definitely can help love and also allow
us to have authentic love there might be
other situations when they would be
totally inappropriate but I think there
is a good chance the real problem we
have however we haven't developed the
drugs really well right now we have a
few examples of drugs that have been
discovered but nobody has really worked
hard on making the best love drugs the
best ones for therapy the best ones were
actually helping authenticular love so
we're kind of stumbling around with the
molecules we happen to know about
thank you very much Ella over to you
should we use drugs to initiate
encourage or repair love
well so I mean you know the idea of
artificial has already been touched upon
that the idea of artificial love or
inducing love artificially is nothing
new and you just have to go back you
know through literature and culture the
ancient Greeks had Eros with his arrows
and you know stories like Tristan is old
and people shortcutting the barriers
that they might face in their way
whether it be geography or social status
or someone not fancying you and
shortcutting that with some kind of Love
Potion or some kind of God with you know
favor on your side doing it for you but
they you know across the years and the
centuries they all have one thing in
common they all end in disaster they all
end in death tragedy destruction
um someone finding out and you know as
as answer said you know the immorality
of forcing
um Love on someone through artificial
means is quite obvious
um but I think the thing I want to sort
of investigate across the aisle we have
is that you know the reason why this
happens it's not just because it's in
immoral oral to make someone love you
when they don't or you're not sure about
it but because love is not a simple
thing that you can shortcuts you can't
hack it and it's neither simple and it's
neither an isolated experience I think
probably this is the biggest issue I
have with the idea of
um drugs individually being used to
induce some kind of feeling of Love is
that for me whether it's as Rupert's
talked about familial love friendship
love romantic love the important thing
is that it's not an isolated experience
you know it takes to to Tango you have
to have someone else to experience that
with you and to deepen the understanding
of it the very human nature of the idea
of Love is that it's a social thing and
I'm incredibly skeptical and
disheartened today with the folk
contemporary focus on things like
self-care self-love and you know that's
not to say I don't put on a face pack
and a crappy movie myself sometimes and
indulge in whatever the hell it is but
this idea that the true meaning of love
is to be found within yourself in your
individual life and that that sort of
should be enough for you and then maybe
if you end up in bed with someone or
married to someone you know that's just
a bonus
um
and obviously I've got nothing against
drugs per se you know if the two of you
want to go out into the hills and take a
few mushrooms and roll around together
and tell each other that you love each
other that's fine and that's you know
I'm I hope you have a good time
um and and you know lots of people do it
and there's there's really I don't see
anything wrong with that in general but
I just can't get on board with the idea
that that means something substantial if
we're talking about you know
philosophically or morally or
universally what the idea of love should
be or an aspiration of what love should
be because I think the key thing is that
love is and this is perhaps something
that no one has said yet is that love is
not one-dimensional the power of love me
it has to include within it pain and
death and destruction you know the
reason why that moment when you're first
falling in love with someone or you
first meet a friend is so sweet is
because half of you is always worried
that they're not they don't love you
back or that it you might not be enough
and that's kind of what drives you
forward and that's the thing that keeps
you waiting by the phone and obviously
when you if you do end up with someone
romantically and you are going to be
with them for the rest of the life your
life there's that human biological clock
ticking in the back of your head that
says one day one of us is gonna die and
that's the tragedy of love which is that
it all is always going to end in loss in
one way or another and that's part of
what makes it so powerful you can't have
true love in whatever form it takes you
know between friends and family or
lovers without the understanding that it
also contains deep and visceral pain and
so I think you know any kind of
artificial means of trying to explore
that through drugs taking appeal or
potion or something in order to feel
that pleasure is leaving out the
important pain bit and I sort of you
know you can I was looking for a good
Shakespeare quote trying to find
something to capture it you know the man
who wrote so much about love and I came
across this one from you know love is a
smoke and it's made with the fume of
size no you know no bonus points to
understanding that's from Romeo and
Juliet one of the most famous love
stories ever written and I picked it
because the fume I thought maybe that
would be relevant to a discussion about
drugs but that you know encapsulating
this idea that you know yes love is a
drug yes it makes us do it is the
pursuit of it is something that is meant
to be centrally around pleasure but
actually it is also the human thing
about it is that it is so complicated it
is so entwined with that other Dark Side
of us which is jealousy and sometimes
terrible things like murder and pain and
that's what makes love this thing that
we keep driving after otherwise we'd all
sit in our rooms take drugs and do it to
ourselves and I think that's probably
not a good future to look forward to
thank you thank you to our panelists for
those opening pictures I want to pick up
where Ella just left us actually to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas